I want to show you how to manifest there
are three ways to manifest one is just
sitting there thinking I'm going to
manifest everything but you have to
manifest in three ways the first is you
must believe you are worth it whether
you want love or a great career or
promotion or money or your own business
if you don't do step one which is
believe you are worth it you won't be
good at manifesting the second is you've
got to really know what that looks like
and the third is put into practice so my
daughter my daughter is a really cool
artist she's very successful when she
was little I said darling if you want to
be an artist what does that look like
because well mommy it looks like having
all my art in galleries but what else
does it look like and shouldn't really
understand said no look imagine you're
looking on a screen you're an artist
what does that look like because what it
looks like is taking your art into
galleries taking a portfolio I know you
don't want to do it but if you want to
be a successful artist you must do what
you do not want to do to get to where
you want to be you have to talk about
about your work you know I'm a
successful writer I've written seven
best-selling books you've got to know
you're worth it that's the most
important step eighty percent of your
success is down to having a success
mindset if you believe you're worthy
that will take you further belief
without Talent takes you further than
Talent without belief if you have belief
and no Talent you probably will do
better than some with huge talent and no
belief if you have both you can go
anywhere so believe you're worth it
really take a look at what it looks like
look at it look at it again look at it
again and then you've got to do the work
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I struggle to believe in myself
I quit on my business partner and the
thing that saved me was watching the
successful stories of entrepreneurs they
gave me the inspiration to keep going as
well as the strategies of what to do and
quite honestly I still need their
stories and motivation today as well so
today let's live your best believe life
and learn how you can manifest faster
Joy
rule number two is align yourself with
Consciousness with Eckhart Tolle I was
in the lucky position when I was in a
teenager we lived in a I lived with my
dad in Spain for a few years
and he had
gone to Spain to drop out and Lead an
alternative life and then he ran out of
money
and then when I was there we had so
little money we had
not even afraid I mean almost everybody
had the fridge but there in the hot
summer in Spain North Reds no radio no
rain no television and of course I
wouldn't even think of it uh so
basically just the minimum and um
I wasn't
dreadfully unhappy because of that I
should to some extent I accepted it
because I was still young enough
children
find it perhaps easier to accept
situation at least the the girl into but
normally if I lived in a place like that
now I have no friends I have uh
only basic things to live with things
get
stunned by anything in advance I have to
go shopping every day because everything
goes off immediately
I'd rather move than be here you can be
you can accept that this is where I am
right now it can still be fine but you
would start looking or at least I'd like
to live somewhere else you see this
situation has certain it can have a
preference
and why not have a PR everybody has a
preference some Buddhists might talk to
you about or some Masters say I have no
preference whatsoever
but they live in an ashram
so they'd rather be in ashram than be on
Wall Street and work there so there must
be some preference
[Music]
so this is one thing is dealing with
responding to situations and having
preferences and then taking action
another one is bringing about something
entirely new into this world
and that that comes when you
are able to
become still enough so that you know
what
the universe or the one Consciousness
wants you to do
if it wants you to do something may take
a while before you know that I lived for
years doing relatively little except
doing occasional counseling sessions
sometimes only two a week
and I think the years passed and I was
just continuously
just in presence
on my bicycle
chopping Woods bearing water
and the years passed and and I spent I
spent hours
in thoughtless awareness in London
sitting on the Hampstead Hills
three hours later I go home having a
little salad
on and then having a counseling session
at five could live on one person a day
one counseling session a day
and I wondered my mind wandered
sometimes there must be something else
that I'm supposed to do
[Applause]
[Music]
and there was even slight moments of
what am I doing here
but there was nothing else to do with it
be present just be
going back to Hampstead he's sit there
again
but long there were long periods also of
incredibly Blissful states of the people
noticed even people who were not tuned
into
spirituality particularly say
I can feel something what is that there
were there were great States the
emanation of Peace but I wasn't doing
anything it was just that image
sometimes wait as a waitresses
occasionally I went to little
restaurants they they found something
but still nothing of the universe still
wasn't telling me what I was supposed to
do
and uh
I believe the decisive change came
perhaps I should have thought of that
earlier there was a
[Applause]
[Music]
random to ask I said
and lived in Glastonbury the spiritual
Mecca that attracts all kinds of weird
people including myself
foreign
[Applause]
and just outside is a there's a village
just a few miles out of there so I would
sometimes go there and there's an
ancient like the English Villages they
have their ancient charts sometimes a
thousand years old a few houses around
it there was an oak tree I would go to
an ancient Oak Tree in the middle of the
field magnificent and I had a wonderful
relationship with that tree
but that church that was always empty I
went into that church and
one day I went in and suddenly I had
this impulse say
I want acceleration now I want uh I knew
there was something for me to do but
I clearly demanded acceleration of my
life purpose
and
then I went home again
and for maybe three months two or three
months nothing happened I'd forgotten
about it already and then one day it
came
uh
it came when I woke up and I suddenly
this I knew this as a thought and a
deeper knowing I have to move to the
west coast of North America
why I don't know it wasn't just one day
it stayed the next day it was still
there the next week it was still there
so we could still there and then
finally I had to leave couldn't not
leave if I had not left I would have
died
so that was the first step in writing
the power of now because I needed to be
in the energy field of the West Coast
for some reason
to ride it
and that's how the book started when a
few weeks after arriving on the west
coast it started
and then the acceleration it came more
and more but after the Power of Now came
out well and then it'd be so much that I
almost wanted to put the brake on
but it was the the power just grew and
grew but it it came because for years
I went so deep within
that
eventually the outer
movement into creation the outward
creation
reflected the the depths of years of
going within into just into Stillness
and deep into Stillness
so the outward creation reflected the
inward movement it was just it was as
powerful out there as the part as it was
powerful
the power that that was in the inward
movement
uh so YouTube will find that
the more you uh you align yourself with
the essence the Stillness within the
unconditioned consciousness
the more the Power will there might be a
time Gap but hopefully not as many years
as in my case
there may be a time Gap but that the
power that is within you that you that
you sense when you become aware of
yourself as
the consciousness
then flows through you and that is what
creates through you not the little ego
anymore so you don't create because you
think when I achieve this or that I'm
going to be happy and fulfilled know
that the happiness and the happiness
something deeper than happiness the
Fulfillment is already here now the true
creation cannot come out of a neediness
that's egoic creation that doesn't make
you happy it'll make you unhappy
whatever you create eventually but
either will not satisfy you or make you
unhappy
that comes out of a neediness the ego
operation beliefs I need to attract
something to me I need to attract this I
need to attract that into my life the
non-egoic creation that that
Consciousness uses you as an instrument
uses this form as an instrument comes
out of the inner fullness so the
creation comes from within to without it
creates the outward from within rather
than needing to attract something from
the outside
although in a language you might
sometimes express it that way you might
say I attracted this or that person into
my life but really it's the other way
around
you can only create out of this fullness
that you sense when you're in touch with
presence rule number three is eliminate
the lack mentality with Jack Canfield I
recently asked this question of what's
holding you back during a large group I
was training and there was a common
theme running through their answers that
really struck me and that common theme
was a sense of lack
almost all of the participants said they
believed they were lacking something
that they needed to achieve their goals
now what was interesting to me is that
the things they saw themselves lacking
weren't what you might think they didn't
say they were lacking money lacking
opportunities or lacking time or the
freedom to act what they felt they were
lacking went so much deeper than time or
money
which in truth are quite easy to acquire
if you really set your mind to it and as
I like to say it's never about the lack
of resources it's about how resourceful
you're willing to be to obtain the
needed resources and that's where your
true power lies in you
now what these people realize was that
what they felt they were lacking were
personal qualities like confidence and
focus and the motivation to take the
needed action to create the resources
they needed and all these things are
internal not external what they were
lacking was confidence both confidence
in themselves and the confidence that
other people would be there for them
they lack Trust trust in themselves and
Trust in others and that was what was
leading to not engaging in consistent
action and follow-through
and I was happy that they realized that
the biggest obstacles holding them back
were not external things like time or
money or lack of opportunities and if
they realize that the biggest obstacles
were the ones that were inside of them
because awareness opens the door to
realizing that if the obstacles are
inside of you the solutions are also
inside of you so today I'd like to talk
about how to identify the internal
blocks that are holding you back from
getting what you want in life and show
you a path forward to filling in the
gaps between where you are and where you
want to be so you can achieve your goals
now first off I'd like to go back to
some of those big lacks those students
said they were struggling with one of
the most common ones they mentioned was
a lack of self-confidence a lack of
belief that they have what it takes to
achieve their goals and dreams
if this sounds familiar you're certainly
not alone
because all of us struggle with some
level of self-doubt and it can be really
hard to convince yourself that you've
got what it takes to be successful it's
something you've never done before
especially if you've experience failure
or setbacks in the past but here's the
thing if you know you suffer from a lack
of confidence then the surest way
forward to achieving your goals is to
focus on gaining that confidence in
self-confidence as I've said many times
is built by taking risk and surviving
those risks and by taking small steps
and succeeding and also by making
mistakes and surviving realizing you
survive and you learn from those
mistakes that's how you fill in that
self-esteem Gap you build confidence by
proving to yourself that you can do
things and succeed at them one small
step at a time outside of your comfort
zone and this will never happen if you
just sit on the couch and wait for your
life to magically change
you build your confidence by
experiencing the fear and taking action
anyway
this is also how you learn to trust
yourself by the way and it's how you
learn to trust others as well because
you see it's so much easier to trust
others when you first trust yourself
because when you trust yourself you're
more likely to listen to your instincts
and understand when you're dealing with
people who are worthy of your trust and
people who are not worthy of it
and when you obviously have faith in
yourself other people will sense this
and be more likely to have faith in you
as well which will make it easier for
you to get the valuable support from
others that you need and also to form
healthy relationships
now let's talk about the motivation gap
for a moment a lot of people said the
thing that is holding them back is a
lack of motivation
this is an interesting one because it
makes me ask why aren't you motivated to
take action towards your dreams don't
you want to live your dreams
all of the truly successful people I
know never have to try to find the
motivation to show up and do the work
they're already so excited to do it
because they love what they do the
motivation comes naturally to them and
fuels them to keep going even when they
run in the roadblocks so if you feel
like your problem is a lack of
motivation I want you to dig into that
is it because deep down you know the
goal you think you're supposed to be
pursuing isn't when you truly want or is
it because the idea of achieving your
goals and making your biggest dreams
come true actually scares you and if so
once again you're not alone
achieving big goals requires you to
learn new things and grow and evolve and
that's not always comfortable
it might require you to become someone
whom the other people in your life have
trouble recognizing
for example if you've always been the
shy and quiet one in your family who
never stands up for yourself and
achieving your goals in life might
require you to become more assertive and
the people who are accustomed to you
letting them walk all over you may not
like that very much but their feelings
are not your responsibility your
personal growth is your responsibility
and you owe it to yourself and
ultimately to the world around you to
develop your full potential and become
the fulfilled and purpose-driven person
that you were born to be and if that
means learning how to become more
assertive that's what you should do no
matter what your families or your
friends feelings about it are so once
again if you feel like you lack
motivation if you feel like that's your
problem I would encourage you to
investigate that lack of motivation and
ask yourself am I unmotivated because
this goal isn't really important to me
am I unmotivated because I know that
things are going to get uncomfortable if
I choose to pursue that goal if the goal
isn't important to you I encourage you
to do some inner work to clarify what
you truly do want in life and then
realign your goals and your actions so
that are more in alignment with the
things that matter most to you
because when you're truly living your
purpose I can assure you that motivation
will never be a problem
and if you're unmotivated because you
know things are going to be
uncomfortable then I strongly encourage
you to get comfortable with being
uncomfortable
because all growth happens outside of
your comfort zone and that's also where
all the true magic in life also happens
now finally if you feel the big gap
that's holding you back is a lack of
consistent action and follow-through I
would say that's mostly a matter of lack
of planning and organization
often the reason we've trouble following
through on things is because we haven't
created a clear plan it shows us the
steps we need to take to reach our
destination
and so we're easily distracted by other
priorities competing for our attention
or if because we're disorganized and we
don't know how to schedule our time
properly the good news is this
organization and planning skills are
fairly easy to learn and fairly easy to
implement you just need to commit to
them and there are plenty of success
experts and personal organizers out
there who will show you how to plan your
life so you can be more productive get
more accomplished every day and make
consistent progress towards your goals
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life life and your business I'll
see you there rule number four is take
action with Emily Fletcher this might
play a little bit into the third M of
the technique which is the manifesting
which is basically like you're setting
your intention right of what you want to
have happen and then it's
it's allowing nature to do what nature
is designed to do instead of thinking
that we have to do everything on our own
um and so receiving you're receiving
abundance Joy uh
creativity ideas
whatever nature really has in store but
it's not it's not a one-way conversation
in either direction we don't get to
State everything we want and it happens
exactly the when and how that we want it
and neither is it fatalism it's not like
well I'll just let nature take the reins
and whatever whenever it's a two-way
conversation we have 50 left brain
individuality we have 50 right totality
and so to me it's always about finding
that balance of like yes this is what I
want and oh it seems like Nature has
other things in store so instead of just
fighting it tooth and nail let me see if
I can dance this dance a little bit and
I like that you've talked about how
manifesting isn't just magic thinking
like you still have to go take action to
you know make it come true and do you
worry at all about people
um like getting into that sort of
aggressive push push push mentality when
it comes to taking the action mostly
myself
I like for this book for example like I
really wanted it to be a New York Times
bestseller and my team and I we had like
great Ambitions and a strategy and you
know and I was manifesting about it and
you know our numbers were amazing like
by numbers we should have hit the times
list and then we didn't and so I had to
be like okay well now what you know like
so did I fail did like my manifesting
not work am I gonna be sad about it and
that or do you realize that it's never
about the goal
it's never about the thing that you
think is going to deliver the happiness
it's always about what you accomplish on
the way and the feeling that you think
that goal will bring you rule number
five is have a vision for the future
with vision lakiani my last book was
called the Buddha and the badass and
that title came from a essay by the
great philosopher Ken Wilbur and that
essay was called egolessness and it
starts like this the great spiritual
sages and Saints of the world from Moses
to Jesus to patma sambhava were not
feeble-minded milk toasts they will move
us and shakers who rattled the world
with the force of their ego from they
instigated massive social revolutions
that lasted Generations from bullwhips
in the temple to subduing entire
continents now what Kenwood was saying
is that the great spiritual teachers
were not just focused on the now they
were focused on the future Jesus wanted
to build a legacy Buddha preached
because Buddha wanted to change the
institutions of that time the way the
rich and the poor were Moses wanted to
free his people Muhammad wanted to
conquer and spread Islam to the world
paramahansa Yogananda came to America to
spread the wisdom of India all of these
people had a vision for a future they
wanted to create and that's really
important Mother Teresa wanted to feed
millions of people so
if you really want to practice your
spiritualness you can't just be sitting
on your meditation cushion you got to
have a vision for the future that's what
phase four is about now to answer your
question how much should you be specific
how much should you be unspecific well
it depends on what you're manifesting so
now we can get into a little bit deeper
spiritual ideas my friend Marie Diamond
who's a brilliant spiritual teacher from
Belgium and someone I train with Maurice
says that what we manifest in the world
comes from three different parts of our
being that resigned tension which is
what we desire but that's only one third
then there is a destiny which is what
our soul wants to experience
that's one-third and then the third
piece is the energy of the world around
us our home you know the Chinese called
this feng shui the people group
Consciousness our culture our society
it's all three of these so if you think
of manifesting
you're a car going down a highway okay
that's your life all of us have a
Destiny and a spiritual teacher explain
this to me he said Vision you can't go
for the exit Ram you are on one Highway
your highway is to spread Consciousness
through education you can go on that
exit ramp and go into a different
direction that's your Highway and I've
noticed this about my life every
Adventure I've tried outside this zone
of spreading wisdom and Consciousness
fails it just becomes unnecessarily hard
if I stick on my highway I go super fast
so that highway is the destiny within
that Highway you can change lanes that's
your intention
you can change lanes you can go faster
you can go slower you can go left you
can go right and then there's the
quality of the traffic is it stuck is
the traffic moving easily is the traffic
congested that's the group Consciousness
around you so that's just an analogy to
understand this so when you're
manifesting all three of these pieces
are coming together now in the sixth
base if you go deeper into the wisdom of
how it's designed the protocol is
designed to take all three of these into
account but in phase four what you're
doing is you're playing with intention
uh intention but also leaving things
open for the universe to bring you for
example if you want to meet your soul
mate you don't want to get super
specific because what if your soulmate
is in a different age or a different
body type than what you think you want
Michael Beckwith
the spiritual Teacher Calls this mature
versus immature wanting immature wanting
is oh I want I I only want to be with
someone who is tall and blonde and
um a blue-eyed that's what maybe Society
or what you read in a magazine
influenced you mature wanting is knowing
that your soulmate may come to you in
many different forms and it's going to
be an Essence an energy that's going to
spark that love in you likewise when it
comes to a mission a vision sometimes we
don't know what the universe has set
forth for us and so when you are
practicing phase four the important
thing that we ask people to keep in mind
is to focus on the what and the why but
the park aside the how the when and The
Who
so that's advice from Esther Hicks yeah
the what and the why don't worry about
the when when is it going to come who is
going to bring me or who's going to be
my soul mate or who's going to give me
that job and the how how am I going to
get that how am I going to meet that
person Esther says all of that adds
resistance to that which we seek to
manifest the what and the why add
forward momentum so you focus on that
and rule number six the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is live
what you love with Bob Proctor what
would you want someone to do straight
after they stop listening to this
episode as they go back into their own
life after listening to you today what
do you want them to do what do you who
do who do you want them to be where
would you like them to start I'd like to
ask them to ask themselves what do I
really want in this life
what do I really want
take a pen
and write it down
[Music]
what do I really want in this life
they might start out what do I love
doing
I think that's where you start your
purpose in life is what you love
I'm living my purpose share your purpose
is why you're alive why you get out of
bed in the morning
and some people never figure that out
they never even give it any thought
when it's probably the most important
question a person can ask themselves
if you started what do I really love
doing that's a good place to start do
you know I had a a doctor here oh
probably a couple of years ago now in
Phoenix
he was in a seminar and he said
he was telling me he was thinking of
quitting the medical profession I said
why are you going to quit
well he said you got to put in a lot
more time to earn less money today and I
said well I've heard that he said the
medical profession's all messed up and I
said well I've heard that too
I said why did you become a doctor
well he said I love it
why would you want to quit
well he said because you can't earn I
said wait a minute
I said if you're doing what you love if
you never earned a dime
you're spending your days doing what you
love to do that's a trick of life
I said your problem is you think you
earn money by going to work you worked
earn money you don't work during money
people earn the most money don't work at
all
you earn money by providing service but
you gain satisfaction from doing what
you love
and there's two forms of income one
satisfaction the other is money
it's a material thing
but I said if you're not getting
satisfaction of what you do you should
quit it
because they said that's where it comes
in that's why we should figure out what
we love to do and then dedicate our life
to it
I got into this business I had been
studying it for quite a while and I had
the opportunity I already mentioned a
visiting girl Nightingale 1966
and I was leaving his office right at
the end and I said Earl what is the big
deal in life
well he said there isn't any big deal
Bob he said
it's simply a matter of sitting and
figuring what you love to do and then
dedicate your life to it so the problem
with most people is they never figure
out what they love to do well I'm
telling I can feel the hair going up in
the back of my neck I knew exactly what
I love to do I would love to do what he
was doing I was and I wanted to do it
with him
I had a very busy company at the time
we're operating Canada the US and
England
but I knew that I was finished doing
that I was going to come back I was
going to work with him two years later I
was his Vice President of Sales I wanted
to in the what he was doing be in the
business he was in
and that's where I made the decision and
I love it I love what I do
now
that's what people should be doing what
do I love to do then dedicate your life
to it now you earn money by providing
service you earn money while you're
sleeping just figure out how to serve
people
you don't have to be there you don't
have to physically be there and do it
you can serve people while you're
sleeping and get paid
and that's how you earn money so you got
to learn how to earn money but that has
got nothing to do with
a life of Living what you love that's
the first place so if I was telling
anybody sit down figure out what you
love to do and then make up your mind
you're going to dedicate your life to it
what stops most people what they love to
do they think you can't earn any money
out of that doesn't matter
[Music]
forget about the money
that's another subject figure out how to
earn it go talk to people and not earn
money I know how to earn money I could
teach people how to earn money but that
is not the thing it's to provide service
so the most important thing what do I
love to do sit down what would I really
love to do how would I love to spend my
life
that's what we should do
and unfortunately most people never get
involved in that exercise
I want to talk a little bit about goals
on the line of how do you lose 37 pounds
and write a book I'm just going to kind
of give you that as an example for 24
years of my adult life by choice I
weighed well over 200 pounds I say by
choice because you see I have never
accidentally eaten anything
and when I choose to eat too much today
I have chosen to weigh too much tomorrow
you can choose to set goals and realize
your potential or you can choose not to
set them now if you choose not to set
them you got to understand but the
consequences are not going to be good
down the road for 24 years I was going
to lose that way as a matter of fact in
24 years I lost several thousand pounds
of weight how many of you already know
exactly what I'm talking about but it
wasn't until I wrote it down
put a date on it listed the obstacles I
had to overcome identify the people the
groups the organizations I needed to
work with spelled out a plan of action
set that time limit in there and
identified all of the benefits to me it
was only when I did that that the goal
became a reality and I lost the weight
for 10 or 15 years I was gonna write a
book you know anybody who's going to do
just a whole lot of things folks I was
going to write a book but it wasn't
until I got busy writing the book and
writing the plans first before the book
ever materialized now if it sounds like
I'm trying to sell you on Heaven goals
how many of you are getting close
already how many of you have been coming
convinced right quick like that you need
to have those goals there's no question
about it the immortal JC Penney many
many years ago said give me a stock
clerk with a goal and I'll give you a
man who will make history but give me a
man without a goal and I'll give you a
stock clerk
now the interesting thing is goals do
not care who has them let me give you a
classic example of the way they work in
1950 a war-torn devastated to Japan a
nation which had lost an incredibly high
percentage of its young men their cities
were in Ruins they'd been bombed out but
in 1950 they got together they meaning
industry and government got together and
set a goal the goal was we're going to
be the number one nation in the world
during the 1950s in the production of
textiles in 1959 ladies and gentlemen
they accomplished that objective in
19060 they said another ago we're going
to be the number one nation in the world
in the production of Steel now when you
understand there's no iron ore in Japan
of any significance there's no call of
any significance there we're going to be
the number one nation in the world in
the production of Steel it seemed like
an absurd goal and yet they reached
their objectives they had taken all of
the steps in 1970 the the Japanese said
another goal they said during the 70s
we'll be the number one nation in the
world in the production of automobiles
they missed it folks one year it took
them until 1980. in 1980 they said
another gold and this time their goal
was we're going to be the number one
nation in the world in the production of
computers and electronics yes indeed
ladies and gentlemen you absolutely must
have those goals you got to write them
down you got to put a date on it you got
to identify those obstacles you've got
to identify the people the groups you
need to work with you got to find out
what it is you need to know you got to
develop a plan of action and you got to
write it down what's in it for me now
that's the formula that I have just
given you pure and simple I used to
struggle a lot with manifesting just the
idea of it I would watch videos on it
and I didn't understand what they were
saying I didn't I just didn't understand
it uh whether it's manifesting a lot of
attractions like what are they saying I
don't understand the words that are
coming out of your mouth and I would
rewind it and watch again it's like I
don't get it I don't understand I don't
I don't understand and it seemed weird
silly not good enough for me to just sit
on the couch and think about money
coming into your wallet or whatever it
was that you're trying to manifest you
got to go do something that in law of
attraction you know action is at the end
of Attraction like you got to go off and
do the work if that's been you if you've
been kind of struggling with manifesting
or Law of Attraction you don't know how
it makes sense you rewind videos and it
feels too woo-woo for you let me uh let
me let me explain it from a different
perspective and and maybe it'll help at
least this is what's helped me the first
thing that I realized is
very scientific is from the reticular
activating systems as part of your brain
that decides what to pay attention to
and what to not pay attention to there
there are so many things that are
happening right now all around you that
you are not paying attention to most
things your brain filters out your the
job of the reticular activating system
you can go look it up Ras is to filter
out most things and only filter in the
things that you should care about so for
example
um you know what color are your socks
today what color is your underwear today
you know looking down this street and
you know I didn't know that there was a
pine tree here what are you paying
attention to as you look out the window
you're looking at the tree you're
looking at the the sign here you're
looking at the driveway you look at the
cuddle of the sky you're looking at the
house you look at the what material that
might be you're not looking at anything
again just too blurry you're still
looking at my face you're looking at my
car you're looking at the color of the
headrest you're looking at my outfit
like what are you paying attention to
most things you're ignoring
because there's no possible way to pay
attention to everything potentially the
dog just Anna hello good girl
right we're ignoring most things because
it wouldn't serve you it's just
impossible to be information overload if
you feel like you're overloaded already
just imagine if you took in absolutely
everything so your eyes are bringing it
in and your brain is filtering out most
of it so what does your brain actually
pay attention to well the reticular
activating system
will choose to say okay you've set an
intention right I want to pay attention
to X and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often I I'm I
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things I noticed
was the for sale sign here where I may
have not noticed that as much in the
past but because thinking house boom now
I'm paying attention to the for sale
sign you ever notice when you buy a car
you start seeing that car everywhere
right or even thinking about buying a
car you're thinking about buying an X
you start seeing it on the street more
often why that's your reticular
activating system basically saying I
want to pay attention to those things so
that car was still around right I mean I
I got this car we've got a Porsche and
now I see Porsches more often those
Porsches still existed they were they
were already there I just didn't notice
them before and now I notice them
because I have one right
um so whatever it is that you want
whatever it is that you're setting
attention toward it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car a new house or business growth or
you speaking on stage or whatever your
goals are right it's not just
sitting on it and visualizing it but
it's noticing it and the elements of it
in your environment that when you start
thinking about it right we are we we
consistently think about when you start
thinking about it you'll start seeing
opportunities around you that were
already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected
now your brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things
but when you set intention on the thing
that matters to you you'll start seeing
it in your environment and opportunities
for that to happen a lot more often so
that's step number one reticular
activating system it's the science
number two is to trust your intuition
more one of the things that really
helped me back early on in my career was
I
judge myself too harshly for the ideas
that I came up with and as soon as I
came up with an idea I was like oh you
can't do that or I had to have the
perfect Plan before I would ever take
any kind of action on it and you know
just later realize that
you can never plan all the way out
there's no way you know if you wait till
you have the perfect plan by the time
you start actually executing the plan is
is dead it's over
um and so you have to trust in your
ideas and so the thing that really
helped me is
I believe the great ideas flow through
me believe the great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
that's how you shortcut the brain out of
the equation
you came up with an idea as long as it's
in you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not I
want to I want to go you're you're in a
jealous Rage or you're angry don't trust
your ideas then but when when you're
positive and optimistic and bold and
courageous and an idea comes to you
trust that that's the right idea for you
just trust that it's already and then go
do something about it where normally
what we do is we overthink and we over
plan we over prepare and then we lose
the momentum and then the next day and
the next week or the next month it's
gone it's over it's like oh I can't do
that no that was actually a great idea
for you and it's happened enough to me
uh where those things have worked out
where I come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically but I just decide to listen to
it and do something on it and it leads
to something amazing
the amount of times that that's happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me I had to see it you know I had to
see it enough times come up because I
wouldn't just believe it on faith I had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive State you know put on a happy
song move around a little bit and then
notice your thoughts and where it's
going and what you want to create or who
you want to reach out to what you want
to do like what what thought comes to
mind after you're moving around and
having some positive energy that's
probably the right thing for you and
just test it out by doing something
about it and maybe that's a business
idea maybe that's an email you need to
send maybe that's a friend you need to
reach out to maybe that's an act of
kindness that you need to do whatever
the thing is that pops into your mind
trust those ideas and and you could be a
scientist like I'm I like data and I
like science and I like just I like
proving things
maybe I'm a skeptic I don't know but in
running those experiments I I proved to
myself that yeah great ideas do flow
through me
and so the next time I have a great idea
I'm gonna go and take action on it
so number one particular activating
system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards you start seeing it
like you notice a new car when you buy
your new car you see that car everywhere
and then number two is trust a good
ideas flow through you
number three is the one that I'm working
on that I'm I'm having the hardest time
with and I I believe it and I'm trying
to I'm in the process of getting better
at it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that a lot of the
manifestation a lot of Attraction people
talk about but also
people like Grant Cardone talk about it
that is it's not just
the people who would associate with it
but other people have had a lot of
success where you're talking about
whatever thing is that you want that
it's that it's already happened that
it's not going to happen in the future
but that it's already happened you know
if your goal is to speak on stage then
you're visualizing and you're telling
yourself I I am I am on stage I am
speaking to
I am speaking to a million people or
that's that's a giant Stadium
I am speaking uh 70 000 people you know
I am I am the author of a best-selling
book uh I am like whatever your goal is
and what I think the point of that is is
yes one to see yourself accomplishing
big things uh two to not have a be so
far away that it lets you off the hook
for taking action but I think most
importantly is for you to feel what it
feels like to be that and the more you
feel like it feels like to be that the
more it actually becomes true if your
goal is to speak on stage in front of 5
000 people
and you actually
feel like you're doing it you can
visualize yourself being on stage and
doing it
the goal I think I'm still working
through this so one and two I've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it
if you are on stage and there's 5 000
people clapping for you and cheering you
you just gave the best speech you know
of your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's going to be you and the
more that's going to show up does that
make sense so whatever it is that you
are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that you imagine yourself already having
done it
and this is probably not something I
would tell other people you know like oh
yeah I'm a I'm a you know I'm a speaker
in front of 70 000 people
because because it I haven't spoken at a
stadium that big but
to yourself at least
to say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay I am I am healthy
but look I've got I've got a belly here
I've got a you know whatever I'm I'm I
am healthy I am healthy and and
visualizing yourself being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like you are healthy and you
capture that feeling the more frequently
you're in there the more likely it's
going to show up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and I'm still
working my way through it as well so as
I keep getting better and keep learning
I'll keep sharing with you but
I used to think like manifestation law
of attraction was way out there stuff
that that I judged and that I didn't
understand and that didn't make any
sense like just go off and take action
guys and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um using the reticular activating system
to notice things around me by trusting
that great ideas flow through me and
following through and building momentum
and by talking to myself in the present
moment as if I am that person that I
want to become so I can capture that
feeling and know what it feels like to
be that person
I've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life in business
and I hope it can work for you too you
will never find working a pleasure if
you hate your job or you can't stand
your boss what a terrible affirmation
that is it will be impossible for you to
ever attract a great job with that
belief system if you want to enjoy your
time at work then you must change your
thinking I'm a great believer in
blessing with love every person place
and thing at the workplace begin with
your current job affirm that this job is
merely a stepping stone to far greater
positions
you are in your current job because of
the things you believed in the past you
drew it to you by your thinking perhaps
you learned your attitude towards work
from your parents no matter you can
change your thinking now
so bless with love your boss your
co-workers the location the building the
stairs or elevators the rooms the
furniture and each and every customer
this creates a loving mental atmosphere
within you and the whole office will
respond to it
I have never understood the reasoning
behind putting down or berating others
at work if you are an owner a manager or
supervisor how can you possibly expect
to get the best work from others if they
are frightened or resentful we all want
to be appreciated acknowledged and
encouraged
if you support your employees and give
them respect then they will give you the
best work they can
now please don't believe that it is hard
to get a job that may be true for many
but it does not have to be true for you
you only need one job and your
Consciousness will open the pathway for
you don't have faith in fear when you
hear of negative Trends in business or
in the economy immediately affirm that
may be true for some but it is not true
for me I always Prosper no matter where
I am or what is going on
people often ask me for the affirmations
to make the relationships at work be
smoother
in fact for many people this is a really
big issue in their lives I am deeply
aware that whatever I give out comes
back to me multiplied and this is true
everywhere including at work
in the workplace it is important to know
that every employee and employer has
been attracted by the action of love for
it's his and her divine right place here
and now at this point in time and space
Divine Harmony permeates us all and we
can all flow together in the workplace
in a most productive and joyous way
there aren't any problems that don't
have Solutions there aren't any
questions without answers
choose to go beyond the problem to seek
the Divine Right action solution to any
Discord that may seem to appear
be willing to learn from any Discord or
confusion as it comes up it's important
to release all blame and turn within to
seek the truth
and be willing to release whatever
pattern may be in your Consciousness
that has contributed to the situation
know that you are successful in all that
you do you're inspired and productive
you serve others willingly and gladly
Divine Harmony Reigns Supreme within and
around you and within and around each
and every person in your workplace
when you know and declare that it's
possible to successfully operate in the
workplace according to Divine principles
then Divine love brings to you those who
can be helped by that which you so
lovingly do
now if you like your job but feel you're
not getting paid enough then bless your
current salary with love expressing
gratitude for what you do have enables
it to grow
and absolutely no more bitching about
the job or co-workers your Consciousness
puts you where you are now your changing
Consciousness can lift you to a better
position you can do it
during your work day there are a number
of things you can do to release tension
here are a few ideas
one before you go to work every day do
this simple exercise just sit
comfortably and concentrate on your
breath
whenever you notice thoughts coming in
gently bring your awareness back to your
breath
give yourself at least 10 or 15 minutes
to dwell in the silence each day there
is nothing difficult or tricky to this
and it's worth taking the time
two write or type this affirmation and
put it where you can see it at work my
job is a peaceful Haven I bless my job
with love I put love in every corner and
my job lovingly responds with warmth and
comfort I am at peace
when you start to think about your boss
say this affirmation to yourself
I only give out that which I wish to
receive my love and acceptance of others
is mirrored to me in every way
refuse to be limited in any way by human
mind thinking
your life can be filled with love and
joy because your work is a Divine idea
remember to say to yourself every day
before going to work no matter where I
am there is only infinite good Infinite
Wisdom infinite Harmony and love your
beliefs affect your world you believe
certainly affect your biochemistry I've
had women of 58 say could you make me
pregnant I go I know it's too late why
did you wait 30 years but the mind will
follow your instructions and it's very
important to give yourself the right
instruction of course there are limit
you can't tell yourself you're going to
be an astronaut and when people said I
want to be a millionaire like what are
you going to do to be a millionaire you
can't go wrong with sit at home and
that's the problem with the secret
attract Millions to you what are you
going to do for these I want to be have
a six-pack you do need to go to the gym
I want to have great health well stop
eating pizza and eat better food but
once you get the mind to one wanted is
actually easy but when people say to me
I want to be a millionaire then we tell
them well any goal of significance
requires you to learn something new but
then they have a fear of learning and
and of course you're right then when
people come in and go I want this you
have to look at the blocks the number
one block is the fear of rejection
if I make it I might get rejected if I
find love they might leave if I may call
that money people won't like me anymore
so you've got to smash out of the
ballpark the fear of rejection you've
got to smash out the second belief that
says it's all easy I remember Luther
Vandross saying you know people say I'm
an overnight success I sang Jingles for
KFC for 12 years
it was a long overnight so you do have
to also have that desire
I mean for me you know I speak in public
I write books always aware that
somebody's going to hate your book I
don't like it I'm like oh that's okay
they can't reject me they might reject
my book most people happen to love them
but to get anywhere in life
you have to get over the fear of
rejection
because people think they're going to
die from rejection but they really don't
[Music]
so learning to create our minds the way
we want is the basis of creating the
world the way we want
there is a wonderful story in the yogic
law
on a certain day
a man took a walk he went for a long
walk
accidentally unawares he walked into
Paradise fortunate isn't he
he just took a walk and he landed up in
Paradise
after this long walk he felt a little
tired so he thought oh I'm tired I wish
I could rest somewhere
he looked around there there was a nice
tree
underneath which there was very cushiony
grass
so it was inviting he went and put his
head down there and slept
after a few hours he woke up
well rested and he thought oh I am well
rested but I am feeling hungry I wish I
had something to eat
and he thought about all the nice things
that he ever wanted to eat in his life
and instantly all those things appeared
in front of him you need to understand
they have the services like that
[Music]
don't ask questions food came and he ate
stomach became full then he thought
oh my stomach is full I wish I had
something to drink
[Music]
all the nice things that he ever wanted
to drink
he thought about it and all of them just
appeared
drinking people also don't ask questions
so he drank
now with a little bit of alcohol in him
you know Charles Darwin told you all of
your monkeys your tail fell away not me
Charles Darwin told you that you were
all monkeys and your tail fell away and
then you became human yes definitely the
tail fell away but the monkey
in yoga we always refer to an
unestablished mind
as murkata which means a monkey
why we are referring to the Mind as a
monkey is
what are the qualities of a monkey one
thing about a monkey is it's a necessary
moment
[Music]
and another thing about the monkey is
if I say you're monkeying somebody what
does it mean imitation
monkey and imitation have become
synonymous
so these two essential qualities of a
monkey are very much the qualities of an
unestablished mind unnecessary moment
you don't have to learn it from the
monkey you can teach it to the monkey
and imitation is full-time job of the
Mind
so when these two qualities are on a
mind is referred to as a monkey
so this monkey became active within him
he just looked around thought what the
hell is happening here
I asked for food food came
I asked for drink drink came
there must be ghosts around here
and ghosts came
all the ghosts have come they're going
to surround me and torture me he thought
immediately the ghosts surrounded him
and started torturing him
then he started screaming in pain and
said oh they're going to kill me and he
died
just now he said he's a fortunate being
the problem is he was sitting under a
kalpa rickshaw or a wishing tree
he asked for food food came he asked for
drink drink came he asked for ghosts
ghost came he asked for torture torture
came he asked for death death happened
now don't go looking for these kalpa
rukshas in the forest you can barely
find a tree
these days
a well-established mind
a mind which is in a state of samyukti
is referred to as a cultivation
if you organize your mind
to a certain level of organization it in
turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything gets organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body
your mind your emotion and the
fundamental life energies are organized
in One Direction once you are like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in One Direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
so organizing our minds and in turn
organizing the whole system
and these four basic dimensions of who
you are right now in One Direction if
you do this you are a kalpa Brookshire
yourself
anything that you wish will happen
but right now if you look at your lives
everything that you have wished for till
now if it happens you're finished
everything and everybody that you have
desired for if all of that lands up in
your house today could you live with
that
once we're empowered like this it's very
important that our physical action
emotional action mental action and
energy actions are controlled and
properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive right now that is our
problem the technology which is supposed
to make our life beautiful and easy has
become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis of
our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible
levels of comfort and convenience to us
in the last
100 years or so has also become a threat
to our life simply because we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means moving from a compulsive state of
activity to a conscious state of
activity
you might have heard of people
for whom they ask for something and
beyond all expectations it came true to
the true for them
generally this happens to people who are
in faith
now let's say you want to build a house
if you start thinking oh I want to build
a house to build a house I need 50 lakhs
but I have only 50 rupees in my pocket
not possible not possible not possible
the moment you say not possible you are
also saying I don't want it
so on one level you're creating a desire
that you want something on another level
you're saying I don't want it so in this
conflict it may not happen
someone who has some faith in a God or
in a temple or whatever
who is how simple-minded Faith Works
only for those people who are
simple-minded thinking people people who
are too much thinking for them it never
works a childlike person
who has a simple faith in his God or his
Temple or whatever
he goes to the temple and says Shiva I
want a house I don't know how you must
make it for me
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
this these things are completely removed
by the simple Act of Faith
now he believes Shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
[Music]
so is Shiva going to come and build your
house no I want you to understand God
will not lift his little finger for you
what you refer to as God he's a source
of creation
as a Creator he has done a phenomenal
job there's no question about it could
you think of a better creation than this
is it in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now
so as a Creator he has done his job
wonderfully well
but if you want life to happen the way
you want it because right now the very
Crux of your happiness and your
well-being is this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is life is not happening the way
you think it should happen
that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it is it should happen you're
unhappy if life happens the way you
think it should happen you are happy
it's as simple as that
so if life has to happen the way you
think it should happen first of all
how you think
with how much Focus you think how much
stability is there in your thought and
how much reverberance is there in the
thought process will determine whether
your thought will become a reality or is
it just an empty thought
or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process
this possible is something possible or
not possible is destroying Humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's Nature's business
your business is just to strive but what
you want Consciousness is awareness
awareness is paying attention and
noticing and so 95 of Who We Are by the
time we're 35 years old is a set of
unconscious automatic programs that
we've just practiced so many times that
we're not consciously thinking about
those so in order for you to change to
answer the initial question that you
asked
the first step is you got to become
conscious of your unconscious thoughts
and you gotta you gotta start looking at
those hardwired thoughts that that you
think every day that it just circuits
that have been fired and wired together
how do we do that should we write a list
at the end of the day or one of the most
common thoughts we have that day like
how does someone become aware you don't
have to do that you just have to sit
down close your eyes and not move and
then you'll get you'll you'll start
seeing what am I thinking about right
now yeah and all you want to do is
observe the thought because
when you begin to observe that thought
you're no longer the program now you're
the Consciousness observing the program
and you're starting to pull out of the
program thinking about the thinking yeah
who's doing the thinking of the thinking
about the thinking that's who you are
when you're not the program that's
awareness right yeah you got to become
aware of how you speak how you act
becomes so conscious
so aware of it that you won't go
unconscious and let that thought or that
behavior run you you gotta say oh my God
this feeling that I've been living by
for the last 20 years is actually guilt
I didn't know it was guilt because it
just feels like me and all of a sudden
as you start becoming conscious of it
you're beginning to objectify your
subjective self you're you're pulling
out of those programs and nobody likes
to do that because it's uncomfortable
they'd rather turn on their cell phone
start texting get on the internet you
know watch TV to distract them from that
moment and that is what they have to
move through in order to get to their to
their own personal freedom so the first
step is becoming conscious and
meditation means to become familiar with
to become conscious of to to become so
conscious of your unconscious self that
you won't go unconscious to any thought
any Behavior or emotion and get ready
because it takes a tremendous amount of
energy
to do that and awareness to stay
conscious and so
we fall from grace yeah fine you got it
you got you're awake you got another day
let's go again how often do you fall oh
my gosh I mean how many times have I
done it thousands but I'm not gonna give
up because the moments in which I do
connect or the moments that I do have
that transcendental experience
what matters the most after it when I
have that transcendental moment I look
back
and all of those difficult meditations
those difficult days and those are the
ones you remember you don't remember the
good meditations you remember the ones
where you came up against yourself and
you went a little further and you said
I'm gonna go a little further and go a
little further or you had a rough day
and you just went in and you just you at
the end of the day you surrender and you
have the classic Oh My God moment
there's no linear correlation it's just
whether you're willing to live in
creation instead of living in survival
and so
um you get better at it you know we just
get better at it and for me
um staying conscious and staying where
and staying present
is an art because you you know when
someone's present with you in your life
because they're paying attention to you
you know when they're not present with
you because they're not paying attention
to you so imagine this field of
information this this intelligence that
lives within you and I that's governing
everything material in this world it's a
self-organizing intelligence
you have access to it so you better get
present with it as well as you can get
present with anything else and just
because you can't see it doesn't mean it
doesn't exist right and that that that
realm you can't experience with your
senses you can only experience with your
awareness so then people have to take
their attention off their bodies and go
from a somebody to a nobody take their
attention off the people in their life
and go from that they identify with and
go from a someone to a no one take their
attention off the things in their life
their cell phone their computer their
car and go from something to nothing
take their attention off where they
sleep where they work where they're
sitting and go from somewhere to Nowhere
take their attention off the predictable
future and the familiar past and time
and go from some time to no time and now
if you're taking all of your attention
off of everything material in this
three-dimensional reality now there's
only one other thing that's left that
means you're an awareness your
Consciousness and now that is the bridge
that is the door to the quantum field
and you can't enter the quantum field as
a somebody so if someone has spent their
whole life working on having the perfect
body or so much so they have so much
attention on their pain where you place
your attentions where you place your
energy it's going to take some work for
them to take all of their attention off
their body right because they'll go
they'll do it and then they'll go back
let's see if the Pain's still there oh
the Pain's still there so it's a little
bit of a waltz in the beginning but as
people start applying this you start
getting better at it the beautiful thing
about monk life is half the day is self
and half the day is service that's how
you're taught to live okay so the
morning hours are for you to fill
yourself it's almost like putting on
mental emotional and physical armor like
that's what a morning routine is odd
days are tiring our days are busy our
days are draining well guess what if you
didn't put your armor on in the morning
and you're going out to battle
how many knives are going to cut you how
many swords are going to pierce you how
many wounds are you going to come home
with how many of you come back home
feeling wounded I come back home feeling
wounded sometimes but guess what if you
put your armor on in the morning a
warrior would never go out onto a
Battlefield
and life can be a battlefield work can
be full of conflict sometimes your
relationships can be damaging sometimes
your friendships can be toxic sometimes
so we are warriors in one sense and so
without wearing that so for me a morning
routine is putting on emotional armor
which is meant to protect you for the
rest of the day and that way even if you
do get pierced or you do get popped or
you do get cut you're protected and I
know that when my morning routine is at
its best I feel protected I know exactly
whereas when my morning routine is
weakened I feel weak and so for me the
morning routine as I get strategic about
it there's two principles you have to
know
location has energy and time has memory
if you do something in the same place
every day that place now holds that
energy
and this is huge like it's it's just so
big and I'm grateful for that reaction
because people don't realize how how
powerful this is like when I meditated
in temples that were 5 000 years old in
South India it was easier to meditate
because people have been meditating
there for thousands of years and so when
you find a space in your home and even
if you've got like I lived in a 500
square foot apartment in New York four
years ago and I just had a tiny Corner
which I dedicated to my sacred practices
so if you you don't have to have a big
home to do this you don't have to be
wealthy to do this you can find just a
corner in your home that you dedicate as
your meditation space or your reflection
space so first thing location has energy
second thing time has memory and this is
something that people underestimate when
you do something at the same time every
day
you remember it and time remembers it
that's why we struggle to work out at
different times every day it's why we
struggle like why do we feel hungry at
the same time every day generally we
feel hungry at the same time most people
if you've got regulated diet you will
feel hungry you will feel tired at the
same time every day you will look
towards that coke can or that sugar or
that chocolate bar at the same time
every day
and so when you're meditating at the
same time if you're exercising at the
same time so what I recommend to people
well is your morning routine needs four
aspects and it's simple and I call it
time it's about making time in the day
okay so time stands for t-i-m-e T stands
for thankfulness there needs to be even
if it's five minutes five minutes of
thankfulness of gratitude every single
morning and that has to be gratitude
that's specific it can't be gratitude
that's generic so generic gratitude is
something that anyone could be grateful
for oh I'm grateful for the sky I'm
grateful for air I'm grateful for water
that's cool but it's generic gratitude
specific gratitude is I'm grateful for
the fact that I have someone calling me
this morning I'm grateful for the fact
that I can still call my parents I'm
grateful for the fact that I have this
person in my business who is having such
an impact I'm grateful you know it's
specificity yeah so thankfulness second
one is Insight I think this is one thing
that a lot of people are missing which I
recommend people listening to you it's
like podcast books and and make it
easier for yourself if you get this book
leave it open on your bedside table
leave it open on your kitchen table
leave it open on your dining table I
guarantee you you will read more and
what you read will speak to you and I
think people underestimate that that
literally like when you have it open and
you'll just flick to a chapter randomly
and you'll pick up one line it will
impact you and it'll speak to you so
Insight you need Insight every day m is
meditation and I believe meditation is
different for different people as monks
we did walking meditations we did Beach
meditations we did visualizations we did
breath work find your meditation
practice I give a ton in the book and
fourth obviously exercise which you can
speak to even more than I can I exercise
to keep fit you look amazing too though
but it's an exercise everyone needs to
find five minutes a day 15 minutes a day
of exercising
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Joe dispenza
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there the victim is
saying I'm feeling this way because that
person that circumstance or I don't have
any money is causing me to feel this way
that's my relationship with money what
that really means is I'm using my lack
to reaffirm